harvest season is here and it's time to
gather the Bountiful peanuts from our
Orchards join us on this journey as we
take you through the process of bringing
these delicious fruits to the market
first let's head to the peanut Fields as
the sun rises Farmers begin their day
carefully inspecting the plants and
selecting the ripest peanuts with
skilled hands they gently pull the
plants from the ground revealing the
Hidden Treasures beneath the soil next
the peanuts are taken to the drying
facility here they are spread out on
large trays and left to dry under the
warm sun this process ensures that the
peanuts are perfectly roasted and ready
for consumption meanwhile in the peach
Orchards the trees are heavy with ripe
luscious fruits Farmers carefully pluck
each Peach making sure to handle them
with care to avoid any bruising the
sweet Aroma fills the air as the baskets
fill up with these vibrant juicy peaches
once the Harvest is complete it's time
to prepare for the market